how's your presence welcome to basically
spacing to be spacer sorry
basically how you doing
Maci be careful the Heil angry angry
bird you go
I choose you angry bird go make me proud
he's too fat you son-of-a-bitch gravity
I knew that shaka nah Oh fly under wings
of bird fly angry fly the [ __ ] is he
doing oh he's doing something goat what
do you know had God not a helicopter
goat I kept telling him so many times
Jesus Christ he's out of control
he's trying to become a helicopter oh my
god he's flying our Lord and Savior goat
take us to Heaven's I love you
Oh
Oh goddamnit
oh my god okay Missy basically I know
what you're thinking
god damn get Bette yep Bessie god damn
you Bessie
you weren't supposed to start without me
okay ah all right this has to be the
fourth dimension I think I saw this in
interstellar right oh it's our calling
basis being summoned there it is now
this is a real car
Bitsey 2.0 baby whoa
how does it how does it work how does
autumn wood its work come on now here we
are the grid the grid
I like him
oh my god yeah fly to the Sun baby
flattered Asajj yet I'm not gonna and
then we're gonna land we can land softly
softly soft landing we're going in for a
soft smooth landing yes thank you for
flying feet by Airlines we hope you
didn't die a horrible death okay we're
gonna go through that loop let's go baby
night nice and easy though nice and easy
nice and easy enabled thrusters faster
sanic sanic you son of a sanic you piece
of [ __ ] we know don't fly stop flying
Jesus Christ you're not a you're not a
plane I don't know why you think you to
plane come on come on come on come on
man we can do the look let's do the look
we're doing the loop oh [ __ ]
nailed it quit down down down dammit
Carrodus yes fly upside down why not
Yolo I don't know again do it again
alright here we go here we go here we go
we're gonna go here we go here we go we
go we go we go go we're looping Wow
let's do a safe landing doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
oh oh yeah oh we're gonna live we're
gonna live Bob we're gonna live mom mom
mom
we're going to high waiter here oh Jesus
oh this is a fast one damn alright now
let's go through the lube dee dee
no problem no problem what's so [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] with problem like here we go
engage oh my god we go no problem no
problem
hahaha still do it I'm still a car no
I'm a helicopter plot twist Oh what is
this what the hell whoa whoa what is
happening what the hell is this
I'm so confused ah I'm fine Oh hahaha
no what do what you want it's your body
it's free-falling
all right here we go that's my goat all
right
oh yeah go go - goat yeah yeah now look
up your mode engage whoa all right we
are back to play some more I had took a
little break v to the pieces here that's
always driving like [ __ ] seriously Betty
all right let's go with goat where's my
couch
where's my son fine there yes yeah I
mean bad the time
does that even work I believe I can goat
I believe I can go to goat every single
day every night I pray and the good for
you oh my god is that like 5 sec inside
of SE what the [ __ ] get it back in the
boot look at
haha
this should be good alright then good
don't stop me now don't stop me cause
I'm having a good time happen to the sky
like a tagging there we go beautiful
insane raw power rockets what is there
more than what we had are you kidding me
no that's not that's not awesome
let's try this hamster wheel oh oh it's
going ha ha ha
that's awesome alright speed it up a bit
okay what what I barely touched it and
like my I don't know what part of me
fell off are you kidding me how powerful
this is really [ __ ] powerful
oh yeah go aah aah oh my god
let's go inside and fall basically get
out of my way young Beach yeah ah fine
[ __ ] fine
Jesus Christ it's barely a flesh wound
fine like me I'm fine like a perf I'm on
the card
helicopter - if I wanted ah hey legs
like I got it hi fresh gonna have to end
that episode there if you enjoyed
watching hit that like button if you let
me know if you want more I would love to
play more for you and as always